(en ukrainien)
- Sa ferme laitière continue
de produire  plein régime.
Un geste patriotique,
selon Hlib Lozhkin.
"Il faut s'assurer de nourrir
les Ukrainiens, dit-il,
c'est un enjeu stratégique."
La production agricole
ukrainienne, un des greniers
du monde, souffre déjà
de la guerre. Champs bombardés
et minés dans l'est ukrainien,
difficultés d'approvisionnement
en pétrole. Des problèmes qui
font craindre le pire
à l'approche de la ononon
des semences.
Le gouvernement ukrainien
a demandé à tous les fermiers
de redoubler d'efforts afin
de nourrir le pays, mais aussi
de poursuivre les exportations,
importante source de revenus
pour l'Ukraine.
"Les autorités locales évaluent
en ce moment nos stocks et
besoins de pétrole et moulée
ainsi que notre niveau possible
de production", explique-t-il.
L'Ukraine est un des plus
grands pays exportateurs
de céréales et de grains.
Des économistes redoutentune die
l'approvisionnement mondial
de l'ordre de 5 à 10 %
cette année en raison
de la guerre. Le spectre
de la crise alimentaire dans
les pays déjà vulnérables
d'Afrique du Nord et
du Moyen-Orient est bien réel.
L'Égypte, nourrie au blé
ukrainien, est secouée. Le pays
importe 70 % de ses besoins
en céréales de Russie et
d'Ukraine.
Le t t t t le couscous
fabriqués à partir du blé sont
au coeur de l'alimentation
égyptienne. Le prix des matières
premières agricoles a augmenté
de 30 % en un an etleleleles exs
sont maintenant menacées.
"Nous allons subir
des pénuries", admet ce fermier.
Ses réserves de  q q q q quatre
ans seront épuisées dans deux
à trois mois.
En Italpépépépépénurie
de moulée pour les animaux
pointe déjà à l'horizon.
Des fermiers commencent
à envisager des mesures
extrêmes.
...comme l'abattage d'animaux
faute de nourriture pour eux.Une
de conséquences. Rebâtir
le cheptel bovin italien
pourrait ensuite prendre
jusqu'à huit ans.
(applaudissement)
Dans sa quête d'appuis et
d'armes supplémentaires,
le président ukrainien appelle
les élus italiens à prévenir
la famine qui guette plusieurs
pays en raison de la guerre
en Ukraine.
"Nous ne pouvons pas prévoir
le niveau de nos exportations",
répète-t-il.
Hlib Lozhkin, lui, promet
de faire tout ce qu'il peut,
tant que sa ferme ne sera pas
bombardée. Il prendra les armes
à ce moment-là s'il le faut.
- It depends. It depends. I
think... why not? Haha
- L'impensable il n'y a pas si
longtemps. La réalité de tous
les Ukrainiens aujourd'hui.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Staryy Yarychiv
en Ukrain